when I describe myself as an optimist
people's immediate reaction is that I'm
naive or blind optimism is neither I it
is not to be confused with blind
positivity everything's fine
everything's good you know or the
obsession with focusing on the things
that are working and ignoring the things
that are broken optimism uh is is very
realistic uh it allows for frustration
and sadness but it's the undying belief
that the future is bright so an optimist
would say we are in a dark tunnel um I
do not know how long we're going to be
in here and it will be difficult but I
know one thing for sure if we work
together and take care of each other we
will get through this and we will come
out of the stronger than we went in and
I still firmly believe that that if we
work together and we find ways through
that we will come out of the stronger
than we went in and I do believe the
future is
[Music]
bright